and he is Frank stiff SAR Dhoni jr. the
winner of 2016 madden championship game
champ welcome to the program how you
feeling this morning thank you for
having me down I feel amazing on top of
the world right now how late did the
party go after winning Madden odd into
the wee hours of the night retargeting
to at which party I just hanging out
with a bunch of my boys partying it up
how did you win all right in preparation
basically I every time after the
quarterfinals after the final eight
after the final 16 we Ares came back to
our hotel room just kept practicing just
kept laughing up different stuff to stop
different schemes for different
competitors in the event and it ended up
working out in my favor do you have
scouting reports of your opponents yeah
I'm here I can watch a path broadcast
for my main competitors that were in the
van challenge championships and I could
write my notes down just like any coach
would do how much did you win around
twenty thousand dollars is just a
full-time job it's not a full-time job
yet they just announced eSports for
madden NFL they're going to be giving
away a combined purse of 1 million
dollars next year if I thought Windows
then we start talking about these I
couldn't my day job and that's our
beauty a competitive madam prolific gym
sponsors not as right now I'm trying to
work on some i just got done winning the
championship so i'm sure i'll be getting
on that as soon as like a home re
roxbury new jersey how much time do you
spend on med ooh hours upon hours I I
need to be the best you got to put in a
lot of effort my sympathies yonce
doesn't like that but she understands
that I'm doing it for for us in the
future my parents are finally giving in
to it seeing that I'm starting to make
some money doing it so a lot of hours
into the lab what are your fiance's
complaints about the amount of time you
put in with madden i'm taking too much
time away from her
you want to start doing some other
things okay but a Saturday night date
night are you all in all I like when do
we do Madden I know I try to you know
schedule myself properly I try and give
myself mad mondays we like to call it me
Mary we call him back monday so she'd
give me she hears me the all day Monday
after I come home from work to practice
my madden other days like wednesday
friday i tend not to try and do anything
on the weekends because that is uh
that's when we hang out that's our third
time to hang out what's your day job I
work I tea for our new york life
insurance oh nice how old are you i am
25 years old when did you start gaming i
started gaming when I was a kid I mean
my first game it was funny my parents
got me doom you guys remember do me I
rated M for Mature they even know what
that meant didn't even know and meant
for mature so then sees me this game
called doom that was a child I kept
playing it had nightmares for years I
thought playing competitive Madden I
like three years ago how do we come up
with a nickname stiff um american pie I
was my favorite uh that was my favorite
movie when I was growing up this place
there you got it got a lot of do you
ever have injuries with madden my thumb
injury is a carpal tunnel ya ha now I
don't have anything like that i actually
got like a special controller so it's
light on my joints do you go for to like
Ben Roethlisberger does I'm going to
start going for two if they're gonna put
the extra point back in which they have
I mean it gets hard taking those field
goals now since they reimplemented are
the field goal kicking system I've
always been a believer in going for two
if you have a play and it's going to
work fifty percent of the time do you
miss it once get it the second try your
there 14 points just like he said he's
the stiff inator he's Frank's ardougne
jr. the winner of madden you heard
fritzie's rant about eSports I'm
assuming but yes I have heard about his
little rant for to do you have anything
that you would how would you summarize
that too
stiff the way I would summarize it is
I'm concerned for those that may be
looking up to like my son's 13 plays a
lot of video games that think that they
can like do this for a living and
instead of you know concentrating on
their studies are they spending too many
hours you know not going out and getting
exercise and running around and doing
things like that right do you get
exercise I get plenty of exercise I
played college at baseball Fairleigh
Dickinson University I go to the gym
five days a week though I I make time
boom fritzy that's good you talk to his
uh his opponent there doesn't look like
he's got the same room all well low blow
well I never said that all gamers are
obese or have them you know glucose
problems or anything like my perception
which may be wrong and you'll conceive
but that's my initial perception because
I don't play video you backpedal better
than Deion Sanders do I mean I play it
affects our bag up some mountain dew
sitting on the couch and playing over
and over and over again till you like a
like Frank Frank the best quarterback in
madness who Tom Brady hundred percent
not even 20 years ago is the best cover
the best wide receiver hotel Beckham jr.
hundred percent I won't argue about that
the future of madden on television where
we headed redness oh we're heading to
bigger and better things I can tell you
right now we're just on espn2 I was
fortunate enough to make it to ESPN on
4th Center which was amazing can't
believe I saw my I even know it was
going to be on SportsCenter they told us
espn2 is the final never knew it was
going to be on Sports Center it's just
going to get bigger and better I mean
they're announcing like I said a million
dollars all together next year so that
it's definitely going to be on some high
networks well Frank enjoy the winnings
and more importantly the title there
when we appreciate you joining us thank
you so much for having me there that's
Frank's are jonat Dhoni jr. he's known
as stiff the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you